bis auch anbrennen da geht es nicht
lange ich gehe schon so vorsichtig es
geht noch mit feuer resistenz selber
mitmachen wort geschafft hey da hinten
ist natürlich ganz auf ihr fristlos
stewart ist laut press sie button online
alter was wenn man zu langsam ist wird
man getötet und ich kann gar nicht
getötet werden weil ich ja bei
resistance habt guck mal wie das
aussieht
ja ich habe schon gesehen wer jetzt hier
unten
toll ich will jetzt einfach so rum
das ist aber schon ein wenig g
martin kommentiert auch mal ein bisschen
grad nicht muss ich bringen
nein scheiße kann ich leider ja ich kann
die lange hoch schwimmen ich bin ja so
gut und ich bin ich im creative
schwimmen noch 15 sekunden was dann
das feuer das ist dann so weit ich kann
ja nicht sterben sterben stärker opfer
ich bin ganz unten des bund wieder
betten vergessen
martin machen wir kurzen moment ich habe
es geschafft ja eigentlich für dort ist
es nicht toll
minute mit 4 ist ja das hatte ich wohl
auch erfreut mich ne das macht spaß
er kommt streng dich an conny ja so muss
das sein
nein ich meine ich mache wie z habe ich
grade schon gedrückt da es zu spät ist
so schön am brennen zu mir ein was
machst du so
nein das wort scheiße durch also ich
habe gerade noch mal was gemacht jetzt
habe ich zwei minuten kann man kann ich
ja kann ich nicht eigentlich alter wie
langsam das ist warte ich immer ich
nehme die betten wird einfach
schrägstrich kühl dann strömt
weil ich also ich muss mich beeilen
als ich im bett mit na ja noch mal
aber wenn jetzt sterbe osbourne ich denn
nun bestimmt da musste ich tippe ich bin
vor fritz ton gespannt ja das freut mich
so kaum herr schätzchen motion control
contour lth
weiter geht's dass dort jetzt wieder so
jahren aber da sind wir doch nachher
wieder zutiefst los martin ich habe
nichts gemacht ich fest ich mache jetzt
hier hab ich noch mal wieder fest
okay gut ich war halt in dieser redstone
links bis hinter mir ja ihr schafft man
doch gar nicht doch das schafft man muss
einfach nur hüpfen so habe ich das
geschafft das liegt einfach zu viel
hier ist ein tintenfisch ist auch ganz
cool nein mit schwimmen schnell hoch vor
allem muss ja immer resetten da müsste
man damit man dass da irgendwie schafft
von wegen noch genau ich warte da vorne
und du hast einfach reset ich bin auch
schon da hinten das heißt du musst
sterben geld jetzt schlecht ich habe gut
macht mal einfach hieß es
bis auf
im moment werden rezepte greystar macht
passiert nichts nee aber warum reset
herr seien die scheiße hallo
jetzt sind die pisten wieder angehalten
wie z er geht aber nicht
es sind die pisten die pisten sind voll
am lecken bei mir bestehen
und ich komme nicht mehr raus da warte
ich komm zurück
da warte ich zähle mich eben zu dir du
bremst nicht bei mir stehen die aber
nicht guckt ja jetzt auch bei mir nicht
mehr
ich würde sagen ach so indem wir bei
deep river plate zu gehen ist wieder
start
aber wenn ich auf reset drücken dann
passiert auch nichts aber es geht doch
jetzt bei dir oder ja okay gut anpassen
du bist immer ab und zu hüpfen dann
kriegst du nicht so viel schaden ich
merke schon dass ich gleich wieder tot
bin bevor ich überhaupt im normalen
level da hinten bin was machen die
tintenfisch thaddäus kann die s bahn
halt in gewässern einwohner gefragt was
machst du so die pisten sind angehalten
egal wie sagte seitz gabriel
scheiße man schon sagen die map ist doof
wie gut du hast ich war das mikrofon
hoch an von der stimme ja ich weiß
gott die tür offen und sie dazu das geht
nicht
martin ist bestimmt auch die tür offen
ich hab's geschafft
der rapper ist tricky guck mal was für
ein witziger raum
wow ok ich hab's geschafft da oben ist
eine tür very nice open stage alkohol
ganz viele apps und ein helm für dich
und für mich eine tolle qualität zurück
nein geht nicht tipp da hast du bei
apple
du bist bei belgrad unsichtbar ich habe
sogar ein apfel mehr gegeben als ich
habe breite bist so lieb so jetzt mal
nach oben
nein ich hab das nicht glaube ich noch
geschafft so ja nach hoch das loch in
der decke warum also ich weiß nicht ein
hühnchen dienten hähnchen final quest 2
infozoom warte in vollem wissen das
blablabla okay das ist nur so scheiße
plate crestani final quest 1 gekommen
ich habe den server office i o gott ich
habe angst weil ich erst mal das
schlafen gehen deswegen freue mich
darüber
moment mal was ist denn hier der tür
ich liege im bett ich habe essen kennen
aber ich habe es angefangen dann schön
aber komplett mama
und was ist hier drin auch essen gut
und hier ist gar nichts doch das was ein
schaf so
ich wette gewinnt oder so scheiß drauf
oh gott oh gott wie dfb teams geschafft
und ich hab fackeln warte mal was ist
das hier ja ich habe einen jazz gefunden
beyblade dilemma hier hast du dann
letter ja was passiere wenn die scores
voll cool von was wenn man es auf den
blättern läuft ich habe meine schalter
mit zwei pressure plates ja ich war ja
irgendwie keinen sound vielleicht nehme
ich einfach deinen sound oder soll
mal schauen wie ich das mache ich hab da
hier options maximal bitte entschuldigen
mehr geht einfach bei mir geht einfach
kein sound ich weiß nicht warum wenn die
swiss schreibt einfach in die kommentare
na ja auch was er will das skelett 0
jetzt eine kiste mit schwert okay gut
ich habe die ganzen alta moda skeletten
martina binnig doch dabei ich mich das
gerät kann man ich will mal war eine
parade ging ein magic box geschafft
jedoch hier sind betten kommentar haut
dicht hält adac procar resistance mir
geht's nicht lang
vielleicht tot ja also ich bin im moment
ich kann jetzt nicht einfach so sterben
mein gott wo geht's lang
ganz ganz vorsichtig nein ich bin kannte
bis auch anbrennen da geht's nicht lange
ich gehe schon so vorsichtig es geht
noch danke bisserl a vision fast am ende
da geht es nicht lange scheiße
ja ich hab den ausgang
ich bin zwei schalter scheiße da kommt
lava aus [ __ ] das war doch nicht so
richtig der ausgang
ich hab den ausgang dass eine kiste mit
brot 3 martin kann mit kuckuck das habe
ich jetzt gemacht aber für eine kacke
ich habe schalter gedrückt hat hahaha
lokal da war ich auch schon das nichts
dabei die blöde kiste war weil nicht nur
etwas wahr was war denn mit dem anderen
schalter oder sonst welche andere
schalter hast du nicht gegen den
schalter gefunden
ja ich habe zwei schalter gedrückt auch
vielleicht weiter für die lava und der
andere führt aber wie kommen wir jetzt
wieder raus so wie wir reingekommen sind
töten
hört doch auf wartet du musst doch nur
gucken ob die feinde stage offen ist
deswegen lässt dich töten
da bist du schon bitter wir kommen jetzt
nicht wieder raus demonstrierten
passiert ja nichts die sind alle voll
wütend auf dich ist mir egal
herbert machen wir jetzt weiß ich nicht
also ich beschäftige mich gerade ja aber
wir müssen ja irgendwie hatte vielleicht
wenn man hier was rein wirft das auch
nicht offen
hey da muss irgendwas im labyrinth sein
laster noch mal kurz gucken ja sehr gut
und ich bin tot opfer
so wo bist du auch da hier geht's nicht
so lange keine ahnung oder keine ahnung
das verstehe ich nicht mehr das onyx
ich gehe noch mal zur kiste jetzt
wirklich nur die kiste wenn ich die
abbau ist der onyx keine blogger stellen
lukas eine kiste ich hab so wie
eingesetzt und hier ist auch nix aber
ich habe alte schalter gedrückt
ich habe eine idee eine vermutung
bei den betten ist irgendwie raus kommen
in den displays ist drin
nein da waren ja die ganze welt da drin
hahaha ich verstehe es nicht ein
bisschen du jetzt hier bin ich wohl gar
nicht auf schweikert sagen ich sehe da
gar nicht drüber f1 muss ja erst mal
hier und jetzt finde mich gott
alles einmal bist du nicht triffst oder
wie ja ich hab dich weiter wir können
vielleicht irgendwie hierdurch bei mir
bist unsichtbar
deswegen finde ich doch cook dem blog
post sehe ich dich nicht
ja man warte ich noch nicht mal ganz
kurz im creative mode ich sehe ich ihn
einfach nur kurz um zu gucken ob wir
vielleicht falsch gegangen sind
halo aber haben wir noch keine
kandidaten jahr zurückgegangen das heißt
wir haben sehr theoretisch schon oder
aber vor bist du vor dir
nein ich sehe hier kein du bist bei mir
unsichtbar warten wenn jetzt die finals
zwei offen ist
das ist offen das heißt schon geschafft
wir sind irgendwie ich zurückgekommen
keine ahnung warum siehst mich denn
jetzt bist du ja hier ist gut
ich sehe und töte dich einmal ja dann
töte dich eben einmal jetzt tipi mich ja
es ist richtig doch adventure park
wir müssen hier ein links in packen ja
erstmal müssen wir denn hier suchen
ich gehe einfach stumpf geradeaus ok ich
gelinsky hier ist ich gehe rechts reicht
da sollte man eigentlich immer links
gehen lesen selber und links ich glaube
als rechts jetzt auch nicht meine
tochter geht nicht und mehr gibt's auch
nicht lang besser als dieses blöde
springen da muss ich dir recht geben
da hab ich irgendwie ich hab' ich fühle
dass ich hab' ich hab's ich hab' ich
glaube aber jetzt anregen was weil es
ist sondern ein baum und einen matchball
hier geht's dann wieder raus okay gut
für mich habe ich bin jetzt muss ich
noch herausfinden wie du nicht noch nie
gesehen jetzt hab ich mich verlaufen
wenn dir da hier die map sowie tff von
hoffe ich die ganze zeit
ich glaube ich bin hier angekommen ich
habe keinen plan
ja da ist der ausgang major ist kein
ausgang nicht jetzt eine tür der
verbrecher plate oder sind wir durch die
reihen gekommen
nein
ich habe den ausgang sie zu meinen namen
hier ja hast du den setzling und bommel
ja muss bauen wir jetzt auf den
setzlingen machen okay das heißt wir
müssen jetzt auf den zaun
bist du mann das andere becken
ich musste erst mal hoch kommen und wir
brauchen hier das becken ist falsch wie
komme ich jetzt wieder raus was soll
hier nicht
ich komme nicht mehr aus ich konnte mich
kurz du dir scheiße verdammt gewissen
alter was machen wir jetzt
das heißt wir müssen jetzt quasi den
sony abbauen sonst kommt er nicht weg
aus berlin hier drin
hahaha das auch falsch hat doch nie das
ist richtig wenn man einer stockfinster
was ist da so tolles halte jetzt
irgendwie ein loch ins loch ich glaube
ich ertrinke hier gerade jetzt ein
richtig tiefes loch aber da trinke ich
gerade schön
ich kann feuerrad level up hatte
eventuell schaffe ich es ich schaffe es
ich hoffe ja toll was bringt uns das
jetzt
du musst flint und ziel suchen warum
weil hier rechts neben songs ist david
byrne
ach ja toll und wir finden
warte da ist doch irgendwas da steht
doch bernd mein gott ich glaube dass da
irgendwo
diese halle machen das ganz kurzen stopp
machen
das mal kurz den stopp machen ich muss
so nötig pizzen meine lieben freunde
wir sehen uns in der nächsten folge mit
martin und mir süß und martin sacks oft
klar